Seventy years ago, the nuclear bombs dropped over Hiroshima and Nagasaki
exploded and to this day remained the only use of nuclear weapons for warfare, but with around
15,000 warheads remaining in the world
What happens if we have a nuclear war? The impact of a single nuclear bomb depends on many factors like the weather, weapon design,
geographical layout of where the bomb hits and if it explodes in the air or [on] the ground. Approximately
35 percent of the energy comes in the form of thermal radiation or heat
since thermal radiation
Travels at approximately the speed of light the flash of light and the heat comes several seconds before the blast wave and this causes flash
Blindness to anyone looking a temporary blindness of a few minutes with a one megaton bomb which is 80 times larger than the hiroshima bomb
but much smaller than many modern nuclear weapons those 21 kilometers away would experience flash blindness on a clear day and
Even up to 85 kilometers away on a clear night
Thermal radiation burns happen closer to the bomb with first-degree burns occurring around 11 kilometers
Second-degree burns at 10 kilometers and third-degree burns destroying skin tissue at 8 kilometers third-degree burns that cover over
[24%] of the body will likely be fatal without quick medical care these distances are variable depending on the weather and what clothing you're wearing
White clothing for example can reflect some of the energy well darker clothes absorb it at its [center] the hiroshima explosion was estimated to be
[300,000] degrees Celsius which is over
300 times hotter than the temperature bodies are cremated at this intense heat
Reduces a body to its basic elements the radiation from the blast also behaves like sunlight
So [object] cast shadows where the radiation doesn't directly hit
But most of the energy released in the nuclear explosion is in the blast which drives air away from the site of the explosion
creating a sudden change in air pressure
That can crush objects or knock them down [if] we use a [1] megaton bomb as an example again within a 6 kilometer radius
There would be an estimated
180 tons of Force on the wall of Every two-story building with wind speeds of
255 kilometers an hour within a 1 kilometer radius the peak pressure is four times greater and wind speeds reached
756 kilometers an hour the human Body can endure this amount of pressure
However the winds would create fatal collisions with nearby objects
So deaths would largely be from collapsed buildings all this at one megaton compare that with the largest nuclear bomb ever detonated
the 50 megatons Tsar bomba dropped on an isolated Island in Russia, and you're looking at
3333 Hiroshima bombs combined if you happen to survive all this now you have to worry about radiation
Now not all radiation is harmful. We're exposed to different forms of radiation every day like our phones
But ionizing radiation at the center of a nuclear bomb has enough energy to rip electrons from atoms
But the amount of radiation you encounter is greatly affected by whether you're outside?
or inside in a wooden structure or a cement structure and so on
exposure to 600 rem Radiation has a [90] [percent] chance of creating fatal illness while a dose of
450 rem is estimated to create a fatal dose within half of those affected, but even those who recover still suffer long-term
molecular bonds and strands of Dna are broken and while most repair around a corridor don't which can result in future genetic mutations and
increased probability of cancer
Then there is the fallout
When a bomb is detonated on or near the surface of the Earth the blast creates a crater and the material that used to be
Deposited in the crater is carried up [into] the air as vaporized dirt particles forming the familiar mushroom cloud these particles become radioactive
And eventually condense and come back down as fallout
depending on wind conditions
Radioactive fallout can travel for hundreds of miles and though it can fall in the form of black rain for the most part you can't
detect fallout with your senses luckily fallout radiation
Decays Fairly quickly and within two weeks material will have declined to about 1% of its initial radiation level
But you would have to stay in a shelter
Until then so what is a Multi bomb Nuclear war broke out a recent study?
Imagined what 100 detonated warheads the approximate size of a her ocean bomb would look like if India and Pakistan went to war
These two nations have relatively small stockpiles of weapons
Compared to countries like the us Russia and China however this would still do huge damage
after the Nuclear Exchange 5 megatons of [Blackrock] would immediately enter the atmosphere
Causing global temperatures to fall and receive 9% less rain annually, [though]
these changes sound small they could be enough to Trigger crop failures and famine a
separate study estimated two billion people would starve in the wake of a
100 a bomb war so what should you do we created a video called how to survive a nuclear war that looks into strategies for
Safety in the event of a nuclear bomb near you which you can click on here to check out
Don't forget to [subscribe] for more weekly science videos every Thursday and click that bell to make sure you get notifications for our videos
We'll see you next week